I understand all the waiters here all
the Italian waiters out of respect for
the game are only groping the women with
their feet we're here in Nevada Smith
doesn't look good right now for jolly
old England the fans are not happy
England just lost to Italy I'm going to
try and help them you married Italy okay
yes make it out on these guys stealing
train terrifying
[Music]
[Music]
I swear to God I was on your side look I
got the Jersey right and look I did the
teeth make revenge on Italy head puppies
- no Li's cannoli
[Music]
this is a welcome relief from those
hooligans from England in a nice
Japanese restaurant where everyone is
watching the game with the
quintessential Japanese respect and
traditional behavior good evening good
evening good evening I am I am most
honored to be here and enjoy the game
with you this competition on the
television I am most honored may I add
that the Japanese World Cup team is a
most impressive assemblage of very very
able-bodied soccer players for me to
poop on arigato arigato may I point out
with due respect that Japan is playing
Ivory Coast very large men in the Ivory
Coast I have noticed that tonight's game
represents the largest penis size
differential
arigato
I am oh sorry for you then arigato
arigato
our evening takes us to East Harlem
where fans of the Ivory Coast are
spinning
[Applause]
go go go let go let go let go my god I
think they got the gold every what
happened what's happened Ivory Coast won
the coin flip what happened here is I'm
good luck
it's good luck yes oh yes okay how about
down here
[Applause]
you